it doesn't take much you could take this  movement and also and it just ripped a  little bit  right and that three millimeters makes a  big difference you know normally it's  like  two months and we're like go we're gonna  be two months okay really carefully  slowly i don't want you starting to  bench press and do stuff like that  you're gonna be slowly starting to do  stuff  you'll be right i'm not worried about  you okay it's pretty tough  i think you'll watch then i'll get out  and come out from outside  yeah you'll be right i mean it's it's  not like it's fun  no  [Music]  i guess i'm gonna go in for surgery and  i'm gonna stick a uh  a rod up my pee hole